مساء الخير مباشره ننتقل واياكم مشاهدينا
الى متابعه هذه الصور المباشره من العاصمه
الفرنسيه باريس التي تشهد موجه جديده من
الاحتجاجات التي تضرب العاصمه باريس وايضا
مدن فرنسيه اخرى رفضا لرفع سن التقاعد
طبعا كنا قد تابعنا واياكم التصريحات
للحكومه الفرنسيه التي قالت بانها ستبقى
حصنه فرنسا ضد العنف والمجموعات المتطرفه
كذلك وزير الداخليه الفرنسي كان قد حذر من
مخاطر حقيقيه للغايه مراسل العربيه حسين
قنيبر هذا اليوم ذكر بان هناك
وساطه يعني هذه تطبخ في فرنسا
طبعا حل هذا
الاشكال او هذا
الموضوع لكن الحكومه الفرنسيه
ان تقول باللا وساطه في وقت يمكن الحديث
بشكل مباشر مع جميع الفرنسيين كما في
الشريط الاخبار العاجله اسفل الشاشه اذا
موجه جديده من الاحتجاجات لليوم العاشر
والاضرابات كذلك على مستوى البلاد مسيرات
نتابعها واياكم الان على الشاشه
وفي هذه الصورتين المنقسمتين الان على
شاشه العربيه الحكومه الفرنسيه اذا انطلبت
من الاحزاب ومن القوى السياسيه ادانه
العنف والتاكيد على الفصل بين السياسه
والعنف كذلك كما نتابع واياكم في هذه
الصور اذا الحكومه الفرنسيه اكدت انها
ستبقى حصنه فرنسا ضد العنف والمجموعات
المتطرفه
العنيفه اذا هذه الاحتجاجات الرافضه لخطط
الرئيس ايمانويل ماكرون للتاخير طبعا سن
التقاعد عامين ليصبح اربعه وستين عاما اذن
هذا هو القانون الجديد وهذه الاحتجاجات
التي
طبعا نشاهدها واياكم الان على الشاشه اذا
اليوم فرنسا تشهد يوما عاشرا من التظاهرات
ضد اصطلاح النظام التقاعدي الذي تقابله
معارضه شعبيه كبيره كما نشاهد الان على
شاشه العربيه في جو اوصف بانه جو متوتر
يتنامى فيه هذا التوتر ازدياد اعمال العنف
التي تعمل الحكومه الفرنسيه على تهدئتها
كما قالت لكن حتى هذه اللحظه كما يرى
مراقبون دون جدوى الاحتجاجات تفاقمت اليوم
في اليوم العاشر طبعا لهذه الاحتجاجات ضد
التعديل الذي طرحه الرئيس الفرنسي منويل
ماكرون ورفع سن التقاعد من 62 عاما الى 64
عاما منذ تبنت الحكومه هذا النص مشاهدينا
دون تصويت في الجمعيه العامه وربما هذه
كانت نقطه الخلاف والاحتجاج ايضا فيما
يعني لم تؤدي اقتراحات بحجب الثقه الى
الاطاحه بالحكومه الفرنسيه وكما ذكرنا
وزير الداخليه كان قد اعلن نشر 13 الف
شرطي بينهم 5000 وخمسمائه شرطي في العاصمه
الفرنسيه باريس في تعزيزات غير مسبوقه
الى باريس ومن هناك مراسل العربيه فادي
الداهوك فادي مرحبا بك معي في هذه النشره
الصوره عندما استعرضناها مع زميل حسين
قنيبر ظهره اليوم لهذه الاحتجاجات
النقابيه كانت صوره مختلفه عن ما نراه
الان الاحتجاجات يبدو انها في تنامي ملحوظ
وزياده لكن اريد السؤال هنا عن نقطه العنف
التي طبعا تحذر منها الحكومه الفرنسيه
وحذر منها ايضا كذلك وزير الداخليه هل
رصدت اي عمليات بهذا الشكل العنيف بين
المتظاهرين ام لا تزال الامور سلميه حتى
اللحظه
اهلا نايف في العاصمه باريس حتى الان
الامور هادئه جدا لا يوجد اي اشتباكات او
مناوشات بين المتظاهرين والشرطه لكن في
مدن اخرى تخرجت فيها هذه التظاهرات مثل
مدينه ايضا هناك اشتباكات بين المتظاهرين
وعناصر الشرطه الشرطه تستخدم الغاز المسيل
للدموع هناك حوادث شغب تحدث في العاصمه
باريس قبل انطلاق الموكب اعلنت الشرطه قبل
قليل انها قامت بتوقيف احد عشر شخصا كان
بحوزتهم ادوات حاده وايضا انها قامت
بخمسه,400 عمليه تفتيش في كل فرنسا
لمتظاهرين كان من المحتمل ان يكون بحوزتهم
ادوات حاده لاستخدامها خلال هذه التظاهرات
وافتعال الشغب كما ذكرت نايف هناك اجراءات
امنيه استثنائيه اليوم خصوصا في العاصمه
هناك 5000
500 شرطي نشروا فقط في العاصمه من اصل 13
الفا في عموم فرنسا لمواكبه هذه التظاهرات
هناك تخوفات كبيره من ان تتحول هذه
التظاهرات الى اشتباكات عنيفه خلال
الساعات المقبله خصوصا في العاصمه وعاده
ما تبدا هذه الاشتباكات في ساعات المساء
الاولى عندما تزداد اعداد الناس وايضا
هناك تحذيرات كذلك من وزير الداخليه
الفرنسي قال ان هناك عدد كبير من عناصر او
من شبان اليسار المتطرفين الذين يتواجدون
في هذه التظاهرات وايضا هناك اعداد من
هؤلاء قدموا من خارج فرنسا لافتعال حوادث
الشغب طبعا الوضع الامني حساس جدا في هذه
الايام في فرنسا خصوصا وان هناك سته عشر
تحقيقا فتح بحق عدد من عناصر الشرطه
الفرنسيه بسبب قمعهم الشديد وتجاوزاتهم
التي حصلت في التظاهره الاسبوع الماضي
ايضا ايضا هناك نحو
اكثر من 100 الف شخص قاموا بتوقيع عريضه
لحل احدى كتائب الشرطه وهذه الكتيبه تسمى
وهي كتابه تدخل السريع تكون على دراجات
ناريه قامت
بعمليات اعتقال عنيفه جدا بحق المتظاهرين
وكل القوى اليساريه تقوم بادانه هذه
التصرفات التي قامت بها الشرطه ايضا هل
كانت هذه التصرفات بسبب الخوف من اي اعمال
عنف او شغب او مدسين ايضا حتى يمكن
يعني ان يكونوا بين هؤلاء المحتجين او
ايضا حتى مندسين كانوا قد اتوا من خارج
فرنسا في الاساس
نعم هذه هي الروايه الرسميه او ما يقوله
وزير الداخليه لكن مشاهداتنا على الارض
كنا نشاهد شبان عاديين وخصوصا من شريحه
الطلاب هم الذين كانوا يقومون باعمال
الشغب هذه وهي في العموم لم تكن تستهدف
متاجر او محل معينه انما كانت هناك عمليات
احراق للقمامه المتكدسه في الشوارع هؤلاء
الطلاب هم لديهم الان حراكهم الخاص يقومون
بتنظيم التظاهرات خصوصا ليلا ويقومون
بعمليات احراق القمامه في الشوارع لتاخير
عناصر الشرطه التي تلاحقهم في كل
الشوارعهم ارهقوا الشرطه بشكل كبير لكن
ايضا هناك عدد من العناصر العنيفه من شبان
اليسار وهؤلاء يعرفون باسم الكتله السوداء
او البلاك بلوك هؤلاء يقومون ايضا
باستهداف خصوصا المصارف وشركات التامين
يقومون باستهداف واجهتها الزجاجيه لانهم
يقولون انها مسؤوله عن معاناتهم عن
معاناتهم في فرنسا هؤلاء يمثلون راس المال
لذلك هم يقومون باستهدافها لكن حتى الان
الموكب الفارسي يسير بهدوء وهؤلاء ايضا لم
نراهم حتى الان الشبان الذين تحدث عنهم
وزير الداخلي اعدادهم قليله جدا حتى الان
بالنسبه للحكومه الفرنسيه اليوم هذا الرفض
منها للوساطه هل يعني التمسك بالموقف فادي
حسب المعلومات التي يعني تمتلكها او اطلعت
عليها لانها كانت تقول لا وساطه في وقت
يمكن الحديث بشكل مباشر مع جميع الفرنسيين
فبالتالي ما هي الحلول امام الحكومه
الفرنسيه
النقبات اليوم مساء بعد انتهاء هذه
التظاهرات في فرنسا ستجتمع لترسل لرساله
مكتوبه خطيا الى الرئيس الفرنسي وفيها
مقترح اجراء الوساطه لكن حتى الان الحكومه
تقول انها انه لا يوجد داعي لوجود هذه
الوساطه لان الرئيس يمكنه التحدث ويده
ممدوده الى النقبات لكن ايضا هناك دعم من
عدد كبير من الكتل في فرنسا لهذا المقترح
لان على سبيل المثال هناك كتله مودم التي
هي من تحالف الرئيس في البرلمان هي تقول
انهم منفتحين على هذا المقترح لكي يبدا
الحوار من اجل الخروج من هذه الازمه ايضا
هناك اقتراح من احدى نقابات العمال
الثمانيه التي تنظم هذه الاحتجاجات
والاضات هذا المقترح كان يتعلق بان يقوم
الرئيس الفرنسي بسحب الماده السابعه التي
ترفع سن التقاعد الى 64 عاما من قانون
التقاعد المثير للجدل ماذا عن تامين كذلك
المراكز الحكوميه المصارف ايضا التي اتيت
على ذكرها قبل قليل فادي المحال التجاريه
هل هي في مامن من اي اعمال شغب قد تطال
هذه
يعني هذه القطاعات خلال هذه الاحتجاجات
هذه المرافق ليست في مامن تام عن حوادث
الشغب لكن هناك مثلا المصارف تقوم بتحصين
واجهتها من خلال وضع واجهات اما حديديه او
خشبيه لمنع تكسير واجهتها لكن الانتشار
الامني كثيف جدا هناك تاهب امني منذ اكثر
من اسبوعين في فرنسا هناك تاهب امني في
محيط المواقع الحساسه خصوصا الحكومه
الحكوميه وايضا في منازل بالقرب من منازل
النواب الذين يؤيدون هذا الاصلاح والذين
كانوا يدعمونه وصوتوا له سواء في مجلس
الشيوخ او من كتله الرئيس ايمانويل ماكرون
في البرلمان هناك ايضا عدد من التهديدات
التي تلقاها هؤلاء النواب وايضا كان هناك
هجوم قبل اسبوع على مكتب رئيس الحزب
الجمهوري المؤيد بشده لهذا القانون كان
الهجوم طبعا فقط بكتابات على واجهه مقره
وايضا تكسير الواجهه الزجاجيه له لكن
التاهبات التاهب الامني كبير جدا في
العاصمه ويمكن ان نرى في كل مكان يعني
ربما المشاهد يسال يعني بالنسبه للحكومه
الفرنسيه ما هو مبرر الموافقه على رفع سن
التقاعد من 62 عاما الى اربعه وستين عاما
فادي
الرئيس الفرنسي والحكومه يقولان ان
المجتمع الفرنسي يا شيخ وان هذا الاصلاح
او الذي يسمونه بالاصلاح اصلاح نظام
التقاعد يتطلب هذه الخطوه الرئيس قال في
مقابلته التلفزيونيه قبل هذه التظاهرات
انه ليس بالضروره انه مقتنع تماما بهذا
القانون لكنه امر لا مفر به يجب تطبيقه في
فرنسا من اجل تمويل المعاشات التقاعديه
لعدم انهيار النظام الاجتماعي في فرنسا
خصوصا وان نسبه كبار السن بدات تزيد ونسبه
العاملين من الشباب هي في تراجع مستمر
كذلك هناك ازمه حقيقيه لكن الرئيس الفرنسي
لا يبدي حتى الان اي استعداد لسحب هذا
القانون الا اذا ما تطورت الامور بشكل
اكبر وكانت هناك ضغوط كبيره جدا وسارت
الامور بطرق غير التي تسير بها حاليا
واصبحت الاشتباكات اعنف طيب هذه ستبقى معي
ساعود اليك بعد قليل لكن الان ين من باريس
المحلل السياسي اندريه مهاور سيد اندريه
مرحبا بك معي اريد فقط سؤالك في البدايه
عن تصريحات الحكومه الفرنسيه الان تقول
بانها لن تؤجل تطبيق اصلاح نظام التقاعد
يقابله ايضا شارع محتج شارع مؤيد لاضرابات
واحتجاجات النقابات العماليه في باريس كيف
توصف لنا المشهد
حتى الى درجه انه يعني لا يمارس العمل
الديمقراطي ولكن الامر الان هو يتوقف على
مسار الامور
على الايام المقبله اليوم
وفي المزارع الاخيره الاسبوع الماضي
استطاعت النقابات ان تحشد الشارع وان تضم
الى صفوف المتظاهرين كبيره حولت من 100
الف كان الاسبوع الماضي السؤال بالنسبه
للحكومه الان بالنسبه انه امام خيارين
يعني كله ما امر حتى نقول احدهم مر ليس
هناك من خيار امامه يعني مقب حلو اذا اذا
اذا تراجع او غير في هذا القانون عدل به
هو يواجه خطر او احتمال او صراط عقد
الحكومه
وبالتالي سيصبح عليه من الصعب جدا تشكيل
الحكومه جديده بلخص ان الائتلاف الحكم
الان نوعا ما الموضوع التاني اذا عمد الى
حل البرلمان واجراء انتخابات مبكره وامر
مستبعد الان اصبح هو لا يضمن بانه سوف
يهود على الغالبيه لانها سياسيه هو في
موقف الحرج وفي موقف الدفاع ولكن حتى الان
كل الحملات الاعلاميه التي قام بها مكرونه
لم تستطع ان تقنع الراي العام بالمقابل
هناك واقع وهناك امام النقابات ايضا تحدي
اخر هو مدى قدراته على الاستمرار بحشد
الشارع فالاخص على المده المتوسطه او
الطويله وهو مراهن عليه مكرونه او الحكومه
بالاحرى انه الناس بعد مرحله معينه قد لا
تكون تبني نفس الحماس كما حصل
مع السطر وهذا الاختبار ربما جعل ماكرون
يعتقد انه ينكر ان يكرر التجربه خصوصا
هناك بعض الاقوال تقول بان مكرون ايضا
يعني بعض
[موسيقى]
المقرئ يدفع الشارع نحو التشنج اكثر
وبالاخص نحو الانحراف عن مسار التظاهرات
السلميه والدخول في اعمال شغب واعمال حرق
وتكسير يعني يتجسد من خلال الاخبار
العاجله التي ترد الان اي اثبت تقول بان
هناك اشتباكات بين الشرطه الفرنسيه
ومحتاجين
قد لا
يكون المشكله هي ان المشكله الواقع
الاقتصاد المالي هذه الاجراءات كما هو
معروف هي من العام 96 مطروحه من ايام
شيراك وحكومه وقد اضطرا للاستقاله حينها
بسبب كمان نظام الاصلاح السكك الحديد عمال
السكك الحديد اليوم صندوق التقاعد يواجه
عجز يقال او حسب التقديرات والاحصاءات
الدراسات انه من الان حتى عام 2030 هذا
العجز
قد يضفي مليار بين 17 و 20 مليار اليورو
بالمقلسه يبلغ حوالي 170 مليار يورو بسبب
طبعا الكوفيد بعدها بسبب ازمه اوكرانيا
وكل ازمات التي مرت على ليس فقط على فرنسا
البلاد كلها فرنسا لديها الدين العام 3000
مليار يورو وهو يتخطى نسبه كبيره ما يحدده
الاتحاد الاوروبي 30%
نسبه الموازنه للعزل فرنسا
وهي تواجه استحقت نحو اتجاه اوروبا لان
عندها لا تستوفي الشروط الاوروبيه لذلك هو
مضطر الى اتخاذ اجراءات من هذا النوع من
الماكرون حتى ايضا يعني ليس فقط من اجل
زياده سن العمل ولكن وراءه هناك خلفيه
اخرى هي الوضع الاقتصاد العام وضع الخزينه
او الوضع الماليه الفرنسيه اضافه الى انه
معروف انه اليوم الجيل الشباب الدراسه
اطول من مكان في الماضي وبالتالي الدخول
سوق العمل هو متاخر عن مكان عليه سابقا
كان سن 17 سنه ممكن البعض ان يعمل اليوم
قبل سنه 22 او 23 سنه الشباب والرخص الذي
يطرب الشهادات العليا لا يمكن دخول سوق
العمل اذا كل هذه الامور
في الوقت الراهن ان يعطي اي تنازل السؤال
اذا اذا لم يعطي اي تنازل الان وفي هذه
الاوقات الحرجه ياتي السؤال ما هو المخرج
المتاح الان امام الحكومه الفرنسيه المخرج
المتاح بالنسبه لها وبالنسبه لتهدئه هذا
الشارع الغاضب والشارع المشتعل سيد دندري
هو هناك
سوف تلي ربما يعني يقرا رئيس ماكرون وهذا
مستبعد على كل حال انه كل هذه الاصلاحات
هي ليست منفرده اصلاح النظام التقاعد ليس
يعني اجراء منفرد او خارج عن اطار سلم
متكامله من اصلاحات تعيد النشاط الى
الدوره الاقتصاديه في فرنسا تنشط سوق
العمل وتتيح فرص عمل جديده وبالتالي تحسن
الوضع المعيشي بالاخص بسبب يعني بالظرف
المعيشه الحالي غلاء المعيشه اليوم ارتفاع
الاسعار كلها انه هذه امور
يتم الاعداد لها على مرحله متوسطه السؤال
الاكبر من المكروه وهنا الخوف الاساسي
بالنسبه اليه هو انضمام او انخراطي الشباب
والاخص الطلاب في هذه الحركه الاحتجاجيه
لان الطلاب هم الذين يحركون الشارع وهم
الذين كانوا في قلب ثوره
الاستقاله بسبب ذلك لانه الطلاب هم بدرجه
الاولى
هم المعنيون بهذا بهذا التعديل بما يتعلق
بسوق العمل لذلك هو يحاول ان يتوجه اليه
من خلال بان كل هذه الاجراءات تهدف الى
فتح سوق العمل ايجاد فرص جديده تحسين
الوضع ظروف العمل ايضا صحيح ان المده قد
تطول سنه او سنتين ولكن ظروف العمل سوف
تصبح رب
ما ملائمه لمتطلبات الشباب
دائما انه هذا النظام الاجتماعي في فرنسا
هو الافضل في اوروبا
الحفاظ عليه لا بد من القيام بهذه
التضحيات لانه هذه رسالته انه كله هذا
المست
قبل ممتاز اعود مره اخرى الى مراسل
العربيه فادي الداهوك فادي يعني قبل قليل
تتحدث عن اشتباكات بين الشرطه الفرنسيه
ومحتاجين ايضا كذلك في مدينه نانتل فرنسيه
هل من اي معلومات متوفره لديك الان حول
هذه الاشتباكات وهل الوضع ايضا مشابه كذلك
في العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس ام لا الامور
لا تزال هادئه حتى هذه اللحظه الاشتباكت
في باريس كما ترون الامور هادئه جدا حتى
الان الموكب يسير بكل هدوء ولا يوجد هناك
اشتباكات لكن الاشتباكات كما ذكرت انت
تتركز في مدينه نوت وايضا فيرين وكذلك
ايضا قبل قليل وردت معلومات عن اشتباكات
في مدينه ليون في وسط جنوب فرنسا قام
المتظاهرون باستهداف واجهات عدد من
المصارف هناك فبدات الاشتباكات هذه عموما
هي الحاله الامنيه في معظم المناطق حتى
الان الترقب الاكبر هو في باريس كيف ستؤول
اليه الامور خصوصا في ساعات المساء من
المحتمل ان تكون الاشتباكات كبيره في
باريس وايضا خصوصا مع دخول الطلاب على خط
هذه الازمه وهم بداوا بتنظيم تحركاتهم
بشكل مستقل على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
يقولون انهم يشاركون في تظاهرات التي تقوم
بها النقابات لكن ايضا هناك تحركهم الخاص
الذي يبدا عاده في ساعات المساء الاولى في
الليل يقومون باشعال الحرائق ويحاولون
عرقله قوات من اللحاق بهم من خلال هذه
الحرائق التي يشعلونها في كل الاحياء وفي
كل الشوارع في العاصمه باريس حقيقه الحراك
الطلابي هو مهم في هذه المرحله هناك عدد
كبير من الكليات والجامعات تقوم باضرابات
الطلاب يقومون ايضا بتنفيذ عصيان في عدد
كبير من هذه الجامعات واليوم هناك اعلان
عن اكثر من 500 مدرسه ثانويه واعداديه
ايضا تنفذ هذا الاضراب لدعم المحتجين
ومطالب النقابات
للاحتجاج على نافع سن التقاعد الى 64 عاما
طيب انتقل وارحب طبعا
بضيفي من باريس المحلل لسياسي محمد كلش
سيد محمد مرحبا بك معي يعني قبل قليل
زميلنا فادي الدهوك يتحدث عن يعني نواب من
اليمين الوسط يعرضون التوسط بين الحكومه
الفرنسيه والنقابات الحكومه الفرنسيه تقول
اللاوساط في هذا التوقيت يبدو ان غير
متحمسه لهذه الوساطه اذا تراجعت ستبدو
ضعيفه اذا اصرت على موقفها فهذا ايضا
سيؤجج الشارع فما المخرج برايك
يعني قال قبل ساعتين من الان تقريبا اننا
لسنا بحاجه الى وساطه اذا اردنا ان نتحدث
لسنا بحاجه الى وسيط ليكون بيننا
هناك جزم بعدم قبول هذه الوساطه وايضا لا
تعليق
للقانون الحكومه والرئيس ماكو
ينتظران ما يقوله المسجد الدستوري في في
هذا القانون اذا وافق عليه المجلس
الدستوري معناها بعد 15 يوما من هذه
الموافقه يفترض او يجب ان يقول الرئيس
ماكرون كلمته ان يصدر مرسوما يؤكد سريان
مفعول هذا القانون والمناقشات بانتظار
صدور هذا القانون بانتظار ان ينهي المجلس
الدستوري مناقشته
للقانون ما تطرحه الحكومه هو مناقشات في
تفاصيل
تفاصيل تم القانون وليس في جوهر القانون
اي ان لا يمس موضوع ال 64 عاما هذا موضوع
مركزي في قانون اصلاح التقاعد في فرنسا لا
يمس موضوع ال 64 عاما وكان هناك حديث عن
تراج امكانيه ان تتراجع الحكومه يتراجع
الى 63 عاما ثلاثه وستين عاما ونصف العام
الى ما هنالك لا يبدو ان ماكرون مستعد او
الحكومه وماكرون مستعدان للتراجع عن هذا
الموقف وبالتالي فنحن لا زلنا عند حاله
التوتر والتوتر الشديد ما بين الانتخابات
وبالتالي الحكومه مستعده
لمواجهه هذا الشارع لمواجهه تبعات هذا
القرار الذي لم يصوت عليه ايضا حتى في
البرلمان الفرنسي
لم يصوت عليه في البرلمان الفرنسي لكن
القانون الفرنسي الدستور الفرنسي يمنح
الحكومه
حق اصدار هذا القانون وفق البند 49 ثلاثه
وهو ما اقدمت عليه هذه الحكومه هذا يعني
وبالتالي يعتبر القانون انه تم تبنيه تم
تبنيه ومعهد ملاحظات عليه رفع الى المسجد
رفعته الحكومه بذاتها الى المجلس الدستوري
للرد على الحركه الاحتجاجيه الكبيره
والحكومه المتوقع من المجلس
الدستوري يعني الذي سيعلن طبعا بعد ثلاثه
اسابيع
الموقف المجلس طبعا من هذا القرار من من
الصعب ان يكون هناك تنبؤات بما يمكن ان
يقول ان يقوله المجلس الدستوري لكن اذا
اذا كان اذا تمت موافقه المجلس الدستوري
على المبدا الرئيسي في هذا القانون اعود
واكرر
العمود الرئيسي في هذا القانون وهو سن
التقاعد عند 64 عاما فيمكن ان يتناول
تفاصيل التفاصيل بالنسبه الى
المسنين كبار السن كيف يعملون في اي شركات
ممكن اي يعملون الشركات التي تضم اكثر من
300 عامل او موظف وبالتالي على كيف يجب
على هذه الشركات ان تعطي معلومات عن طريقه
التعاطي مع هؤلاء الى ما هنالك لكن هذه
تبقى تفاصيل تفاصيل ومفترض الى ربما لربما
توقف المجلس الدستوري عند واحد او اكثر من
هذه هذه التفاصيل لكن لا يمكن بما يقوله
المجلس الدستوري الكل يتعاطى مع المجلس
الدستوري بحذر شديد ولا تنبؤات في هذا
الخصوص اعود الى السيد
مهاوج المحلل السياسي ايضا من باريس برايك
ما هي الاعتبارات التي ستاخذها او سياخذها
المجلس الدستوري بعين الاعتبار
عندما ينظر الى هذا القرار ويعطي يعني
رايه او موقفه من هذا القرار
المجلس الدستوري ينظر من الناحيه
القانونيه الى هذا الموضوع كما قال الضيف
الاخر دكتور محمد كرش طبعا هذا اجراء
قانوني حكم الرئيس بحسب الدستور
تبني اي قانون من دون التصويت
المدى
49.3 المجلس الدستوري الان عليه ان يحسم
بطريقه نهائيه اذا كانت طعم المقدم فيه اي
اشكاليه للناحيه القانونيه هناك الطعم في
الشكل
وهناك الطعم في المضمون وهناك ايضا في
الاعتبار الضرر العام الذي قد يلحق بالوطن
او يضع الامن في الوطن يعني بخطر من جراء
تطبيق اي قانون معين البوادر حتى الان لا
تشير بعلم مجلس الدستوري سوف ينقض القانون
لانه من ناحيه القانونيه هو شرعي تقدم وفق
الوصول لا طعم اذا بالشكل ولا طعم المضمون
حتى الان يبدو بانه هناك خروقات في هذه
اللحيه لكي يتم تقبل
تقبل الطعام الامر الوحيد هو موضوع
الوساطه الذي تحدثت عنه ولكن حتى الان
الحكومه هي لم ترفض الوساطه بالمطلق هي
قال او او الحوار الوساطه يعني هناك وسيط
بينها وبين النقابات هي تقول بانها مستعده
للحوار مباشره وليست بحاجه لوسيط اذا كان
هذا الامر
فتبين منه بان هناك امكانيه
الفيدراليه الفرنسيه للشغل قد اظهرت
استعدادا قبل يومين من اجل حوار عندها
بعدها يمكن ايضا حتى سحب طلب الطعم داخل
امام المجلس الدستوري الحكومه ايضا لديها
في هذه الحاله امكانيه ان بالطعم يعني ان
تطلب رده الطعام من اجل تثبيت القانون اذا
هي معركه فضائيه ربما يحصل بعد اسبوعين
ولكن قد عمر اكثر من ذلك لان هناك فان وطن
وطعم مضاد
المرحله هي مرحله حرجه للجميع مرحله
انتظار مرحله السياسي طبعا
والكل امام استحققت لانه ايضا النقابات مع
كل هذه الاضطرابات علما انها الان
تعتقد نفسنا في موقع القوه من خلال حشد
الشارع هي معرق معركه قسم الوقت لانه الى
اي مدى تستطيع نقابات ان تبقي على هذا
الحشد ان تبطل تشيش الناس يجب ان لا ننسى
ان القانون يتيح ويسمح لاي مواطن في فرنسا
او عام ان يقوم بالاضرار يتوقف على العمل
ولكن هناك ايضا الاجراء الاخر هو ان ايام
الاضراب تحصل من الرواتب من الاجور غالبيه
المتظاهرين هم كما ذكرتهم من الطلاب الذين
مداخيل محدده جدا او مساعدات من قبل
الدوله
صغار العمال اضافه الى ذلك
الناس التي اليوم تنزل الى اضراب ربما مره
اثنين ثلاثه اربعه ولكن مع التكرار هي غير
قادره لذلك لان كل حركه البلد بدات تتعدل
وتتدرب بسبب قدرات على قد النقل حركه ايضا
المصافي المصافي المحروقات مغلقه حوالي
15% من محطات الوقود كانت مغلقه في باريس
يعني الامور هي الان عمليه شد حبال وكسب
وقت طيب دعني انقل هذا المحور والتساؤل
ايضا لضيفتي من باريس الصحفيه والمحلة
السياسيه بلقيس عدنان مرحبا بك معنا في
هذه التغطيه اريد السؤال هنا عن
شق مهم وهو الشق الاقتصادي وشق الاجور
ايضا كذلك كيف سيؤثر هذا القرار فيما لو
تم يعني
تمريره بشكل كامل من المجلس الدستوري
الفرنسي كيف تؤثر على الاجور في فرنسا كيف
سيؤثر على الحاله الاقتصاديه ايضا بالنسبه
لفرنسا والتي توصف بانها حاله اقتصاديه
مترديه نظرا لتبعات جائحه كورونا وبعد ذلك
ايضا
للازمات الجيو السياسيه وفي مقدماتها طبعا
الحرب الاوكرانيه الروسيه تفضلي
هل تسمعني نعم اسمعك تفضلي
سيده بلقيس
انا فقدت الصوت لا استطيع سماعكم من
الاستوديو السيده بلقيس هل تسمعينني الان
بالنسبه يعني
الذي الاقتصادي يعني هو يرى من وجهه نظرهم
من وجهه رؤيته كحزب يسعى يعني وضع عماد
قوي في الاقتصاد والعمل على دفع هذا
القانون لانه لا يجد يعني ان يعني ما
يقترحه المانع او الحزب ايمانويل هو وضع
حل لموضوع التقاعد نحن نعلم ان ان اوروبا
هي من الدول التي مهدده
بالتقدم في العمر والشيخوخه يعني شيخوخه
الدول وبالتالي هنالك نسبه من المحتمل ان
تكون خلال 2030 هنالك حوالي 20% من
من الاشخاص الذين يعني في كادر التقاعد
وبالتالي نحن اذا ما قارناها اليوم بالنسب
التي كانت في السنوات السابقه لا تتجاوز
ال 10% اليوم نحن نتحدث عن 16 بالمائه وما
سي العشرون بالمائه في نهايه 2030
وبالتالي هو ما يراه هو انه خلال الفتره
المقبله سيكون هنالك عبء اضافي على
المجتمع مجتمع خاصه العامل او العامله
يعني اذا ما اردنا ان نقارن اليوم اليوم
هنالك حوالي تقريبا كل اربعه اشخاص من
العاملين يدفعون رواتب تقاعديه تقاعديه
لشخص متقاعد وبالتالي في المستقبل القريب
سوف يصبح كل حوالي اثنان او عاملان من
الفئه العامله ستدفع لتوفي ضرائع عفوا
الرواتب التقاعديه لمسن واحد وبالتالي
هنالك اليوم خلل يعني في المستقبل نحن
نتحدث عن 20 عاما مقبله او 50 عاما مقبله
سوف يكون هنالك اختلاف في الموازنات اليوم
النسبه الشبابيه يعني ننخفض معدل الشباب
في المستقبل وبالتالي سيزيد يعني عاملان
[ضحك]
على ما يبدو ان يعني الرئيس ايماني
والماكرون يعني بالفعل المتشبت بهذه
الفكره يرى ان الحل ليس يعني هنالك دعني
انتقل لفكرتين يعني اول فكره دعيني اشرح
الموقف يعني الموقف ايمان والماكرون اليوم
على ما يبدو انه لا يريد التراجع نهائيا
عن هذا القرار وهو ان يطرح اليوم حلول هو
يطرحها من باب اصلاح
المعاشات اصلاح نظام العمل اصلاح
العلاوات على سبيل المثال اذا هو يقترح
قانونا اخر او مشروع قانون اخر ينظم عمليه
العمل وليس الغاء القانون الذي اليوم
يحاول دفعه بقوه وفرضه على الشارع هنالك
اليوم يعني ايادي مده من اليسار لمحاوله
الحوار مع
الجهات يعني الرئيس ايماني والماكرون
والتي يعني بدوره لعلها لعلني انه كان
متزمتا كثيرا اليوم سوف يعني هنالك علامه
يبدو بوادر ان يكون هنالك لقاء او حوار
بين الاطراف او النقابات اليساريه ايضا مع
الرئيس لاطفاء حلول لان الحجه التي قالها
ايمان والمكرون حتى في خطابه منذ يومين
وفي المقابله الخاصه التي جرت الحجه التي
قالها ان ان اللقابات العماليه لم تضع اي
حل جديد
لتخطي هذه الازمه الاقتصاديه التي من
الممكن ان تواجهها فرنسا وان تلزمها بديون
في المستقبل وبالتالي اليوم تغير الحديث
لان ردود النقابات اليساريه قالت بان هذا
الحديث كذب على لسان الرئيس وبالتالي يجب
عليه ان يقبل الحوار وان يخوض معنا
بتفاصيل اكثر بالتالي اليوم عندما
يوكل ايمانويل ماكرون رئيسه الوزراء
بمشروع قانون لاصلاح النظام النظام العمل
وايضا يمد يده
للنقابات العماليه من الممكن يكون هنالك
مخرج يعني منذ قليل فقط وردني نبا بانه
سوف عمال القمامه سوف يعلقون الاحتجاج
وبالتالي هنالك
بوادر استجابه لنرى كيف ستاخذ الحكومه
مجرى ولكن وجهه نظر الرئيس انه لن لن يقوم
بتغيير رايه لانه يرى من وجهه نظري انه
صائب كليا سيد محمد كلش اعود اليك ايضا
مره اخرى الحكومه الفرنسيه قالت بان
الرئيس ماكرون مستعد لبحث قانون التقاعد
مع النقابات بعد حسبه بالمجلس الدستوري
كما نشاهد الان على شاشه العربيه هل يمكن
ان تقبل النقبات العماليه بهكذا اقتراح من
الحكومه
الاقتراح يعني هذا
استعداد لاستقبال انه النقابات بعد قول
المجلس الدستوري كلمته اعتقد ان او الواضح
ان ماكرون او المؤكد اقول ان ماكرون يراهن
على اولا على المجلس الدستوري وايضا على
الوقت بالنسبه الى المجلس الدستوري هناك
ثلاثه سيناريوات اما ان يوافق المجلس
الدستوري بالكامل على نص القانون وبالتالي
ينشره ماكرون في بمرسوم ان يصدره بمرسوم
وهو يكون ويكون قد تم تبنيه بشكل محكم بعد
15 يوما من موافقه المجلس الدستوري واما
ان يفرض المجلس الدستوري رقابه على بعض
تفاصيل هذا المشروع وبالتالي هذا لا يتعلق
بتبني المشروع وانما بتفاصيل تناقش لاحقا
في مجلس النواب واما ان لا يوافق المجلس
الدستوري وهنا نعود الى المربع الاول لكن
لا اعتقد اننا ان المسجد الدستوري
سيصل الى نقطه عدم الموافقه على
على القانون اما رهان مكروه على الوقت
فهذا جائز وهذا يشبه الى حد كبير ما حصل
مع في فتره السترات الصفر صحيح اننا في
حاله توتر شديد وفي حاله العنف الشديد في
التظاهرات ويمكن ان يستمر هذا العنف لايام
لكن مع الوقت كما حصل مع السلطات الصفر
ايام الستات الصفر كان 80% 80% من
المواطنين الفرنسيين يؤيدون حركه السترات
السفر لكن مع حركه العنصر التي شهدتها هذه
التظاهرات بدات
تراج نسبه التاييد لاحاله التظاهر واعتقد
ان حاله العنصر تدفع لكثير من الفرنسيين
الى التراجع عن عن عن المشاركه في هذه
التظاهرات وتاييد حاله التظاهر هذه تاييد
حاله العنف هذه طيب
حاله العنف يعني هي سيناريو ربما محتمل
يعني ان تاخذ
منعطفا في هذه الاحتجاجات او ايضا كذلك
التظاهرات كيف يمكن ان تؤثر على تاييد
الشارع الفرنسي
لهذه الاحتجاجات والاضطرابات من قبل
النقابات العماليه
[موسيقى]
ولكن الحركه العامه في البلد وبعض
القطاعات هي دائما في حاله اضراب اذا
القوى الامنيه قد تصبح منهكه منهكه وفي
مرحله المراه تستطيع القيام بواجبها
هناك بعض المجموعات الشرطه الفرنسيه صنفت
بعض هذه المجموعات الخطيره والتي يمكن ان
تندز
في صفوف
المتظاهرين وبالاخص نقوم بعمل الشغب اما
من اجل سرقه وهناك مجموعات قد تاتي من
خارج باريس وخارج ومن الضواحي
الموضوع هو كما قلنا دائما يعني في
البدايه تنطلق الحركه اي حركه احتجاجيه
على اساس مبادئ معينه وبعدها تدخل عليها
عوامل كثيره تجعلها خارج الاطار
هذا الاحتمال حتى الان يعني هو غير
غير مرجح يعني ان تصير الامور وتخرج عن
اطار السيطره كما ذكر نا النقابات بدات
خطوره هذا الموضوع الرئيس هو طبعا يضع
الجميع امام مسؤولياته
هناك احتمال بعام اذا تفتح الحكومه
اتصالات كان هناك موعد حددته رئيس الحكومه
لاستقبال الانتخابات
الاسبوع المقبل سوف نرى الى ماذا ستؤدي كل
هذه المحاولات
الانفتاح ومحاولات الحوار والنقاش او
تقديم اقتراحات اضافيه يعني
هناك عمليه شرح يجب ان نقول تعليقا على
مقالات في السيده
ضيفه انه بين الاحتمالات او بين التقديمات
المانيوال المكرون من هذا القانون هو قد
[موسيقى]
يعني هنالك سبل عديده يعني اعتقد
يعني اليوم المتظاهرون في الشارع السبب
الرئيسي لخروج المتظاهرين ليس فقط مجموعه
يعني عمليه اليوم فرض الرئيس ايمانويل
ماكرون قانون
رفع سن التقاعد وهو تكدس
لمطالب للشارع حمصا نحن نعلم ان رئيس حتى
عندما وصل اليوم الى دوره ثانيه من ولايه
ثانيه
لفرنسا كانت لتجنب اليمين المتطرف مع
العلم ان هنالك اليوم انقسام في الشارع
الفرنسي نحن نتحدث عن اقصى يمين واقصى
يسار حتى الرئيس الفرنسي داخل
البرلمان لم لم يستطع حتى ان يقنع اليمين
الذي هو يعني كان يملكه او يعني اقول الذي
كان يعني يستطيع او لديه اغلبيه تحقق او
تستطيع تمرير مشاريعها اليوم لا لم يستطع
حتى من اقناع اربعون نائب في في اليمين من
اجل تمريق قانون وبالتالي وبالتالي تعسر
هذا المشروع في بدايه الامر اذا هنالك
اليوم انشقاق سياسي وهنالك عدم قدره
ايمانويل ماكرون اليوم عدم نضج القوى ليس
لديها قوه على فرض وتمرير مشاريع اذا
هنالك خلل ليس فقط بشان رفع سن التقاعد
هنالك عدم ثقه يراها الشارع يعني يرى
الشارع بالرئيس ايماني والماكرون انه يقوم
بفرض قانون يعني انا تحدثت للعديد من
الاشخاص شباب الشباب اليوم يتحدث عن مشروع
عن رفع سن التقاعد في حين انه لا يصفه بان
ان خروجه للشارع فقط من اجل المشروع
رفع التقاعد ولكن هنالك العديد من التكدس
من الضغط الذي يشعر به الشارع الفرنسي
هنالك غياب الثقه متبادله يعني كتكسير
الرؤوس يعني اليوم المتظاهرين لا يريدون
التوقف فعاملون القمامه لا يريدون جمع
القمامه يا نحن يا ال ايمانويل ماكرون
وعجرفته اذا هنالك اليوم نقيدين ليس
الموضوع سن التقاعد بحد ذاته اذا اذا اردت
ان تتحدث عن عامين يريد فيهما ايمان
والمكرور رغم انه بررر لماذا يريد فعل هذا
وحاول ايضا التواصل من اجل بس سبل من اجل
التواصل من اجل اعطاء حلول بديله ووجد ان
هذا هو الحل الوحيد المناسب للشارع اذا
هنالك ضغط الشارع مضغوط هنالك
عدم ثقه يعني يعني اقول انه في التاريخ
الفرنسي وجود المعارضه وصحي وهو اصلا يعني
اصلا السياسه هنا يعني وجود دائما معارضه
تواجه الجهات الحاكمه هو من من يعني من
اصل وفلسفه السياسه يعني الفرنسيه ولكن ما
يغيب اليوم عن الشارع هي الثقه يعني هنالك
ثقه غائبه بين المواطن الفرنسي وبين
الحكومه التي يراها العديد هنا انها تفرض
بالقوه قوانينها وان كانت محقه ولكن
الجانب يعني حتى ان احيانا ان كنت محق
الفضاضه احيانا او استخدام سبل غير مبرره
او غير مشروعه هي تجعل الشخص الذي امامك
وان كنت محقا يرفض سماعك او يرفض الاستماع
لك وبالتالي عدم سماع الحكومه للشارع
الفرنسي وعد ايضا وجود هذا جعل الشارع
مضغوط اكثر من كون المشروع باعتقادي ان
المشروع هو السبب هذا الثوره في الشارع
الفرنسي اشكرك جزيل الشكر من باريس
الصحفيه والمحلله السياسيه بلقيس عدنان
ينضموا الينا ايضا من العاصمه الفرنسيه
باريس الكاتب الصحفي وليد عباس وليد عباس
مرحبا بك معي في هذه التغطيه كيف تعلق على
هذا المشهد اولا الحكومه تصر
وعلى موقفها طبعا بهذا القانون رفع سن
التقاعد ويبدو ايضا كذلك انها لا تستجيب
للوساطات بينها وبين النقابات والشارع
محتج وملتحب
المعارضون يرون في موقف الحكومه وموقف
ماكرون تحديدا الكثير من العنقاهيه ورفض
الانصات لصوت الشارع ليس فقط الشارع نحن
نتحدث عن الشارع الذي رفض بصوره مكثفه هذا
القانون نتحدث عن النقابات التي توحدت
للمره الاولى منذ عشرات السنين في جبهه
موحده ضد هذا القانون دون نزل نتحدث ايضا
عن البرلمان الذي لم يتمكن ماكرون من
الحصول على اغلبيه فيه اذا هناك اجماع
تقريبا ضد هذا ضد تعديل قانون التقاعد في
فرنسا وبالرغم من ذلك رئيس ماكرون يرفض
مجرد طرح القضيه على طاوله النقاش معتبرا
انه مره في البرلمان رغم انه مر عبر تصويت
الثقه وليس بالتصويت المباشر على القانون
ويعتبر ان الامر منتهي بالنسبه له المشكله
الجديده في الموضوع ان
دخل منذ منذ ان استخدمت الحكومه الماده
التاسعه والاربعين ثلاثه دخل الى هذه
المعمعه الشباب والطلاب طلاب الجامعات
وطلاب الثانويات وهذا بالنسبه لاي الحكومه
فرنسيه امر يثير قلق بالغ ان لم نقل ليثير
الخوف والرعب لان الشباب عندما يظهرون في
مواجهه من هذا النوع في الشارع فيصبح
الامر غايه في التعقيد وغايه في الصعوبه
وادى دائما الانتصار مطالب الشارع اذن
هناك هناك مشكله معقده بالفعل اذا تاكد
دخول الشباب والطلاب وطلاب الثانويات الى
هذه المعركه السياسيه والمعركه
الديمقراطيه اذا الامر سيصبح صعب للغايه
بالنسبه للحكومه ان تتمسك بموقفها على ما
يبدو ان التكتيك الحكومي جديد هو توجيه
الاتهام الى مجموعات متطرفه من اليسار
المتطرف باستخدام العنف وتوظيف العنف في
مواجهه مواجهات داخل الشباب مع الشرطه
سعودي اليك سيد وليد لكن اريد استعراض هذه
الصور معكم مع المشاهدين ايضا هذه الصور
من مدينه ليون جنوب فرنسا كما ذكرت قبل
قليل الوكالات الانبابي ان هناك ايضا
مواجهات بين الشرطه
المحتجين في مدينه ليون الجنوبي فرنسا
وايضا كذلك في مدن فرنسيه اخرى ايضا كان
الحديث عن هذه ربما الاشتباكات او اعمال
العنف هذه صور مباشره
لمواجهات بين الشرطه الفرنسيه ومحتاجين
كذلك ايضا في مدينه ليون جنوب فرنسا نرى
ربما يعني
الدخان في
الشارع كما نشاهد لتفريق ربما المحتجين
وايضا لتفرقه ربما او الابعاد بعض
المخربين كما
وصفتهم طبعا
الشرطه وزير الداخليه كنقد حذر ايضا من
يعني امكانيه انزلاق الامور الى
الى اعمال عنف ايضا او الى كذلك وجود منذ
السين بين المحتجين او المتظاهرين ايضا في
الشوارع الفرنسيه اعود مره اخرى الى السيد
وليد واسال هنا عن التاثير تاثير هذا
القرار على ثقه المواطن الفرنسي سواء
بالرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون او كذلك
ايضا بالحكومه الفرنسيه هل يمكن ان يفضيها
هذا القرار الى حاله من انعدام الثقه
بالمنظومه السياسيه
اعتقد ان انعدام الثقه اصبح موجود بالفعل
هناك انعدام ثقه بين الشعب بين الطبقات
المختلفه وبين الطبقه السياسيه
والجديد في الامر والذي يثير الكثير من
القلق نظره المحتجين للعنف بمعنى انه نحن
نعرف ان هناك مجموعات وحتى اليوم هناك
مجموعات مما تسمى بالبلاك بلوك او بعض
المتطرفين الذين يلبسون في مظاهرات مختلفه
لمجرد المواجهه مع رجال الشرطه وضرب رجال
الشرطه المشكله اليوم ان هناك بعض الاصوات
التي تتصاعد بين المحتاجين بكى تقول اننا
حاولنا بالفعل كل شيء يعني حاولنا عبر
استطلاعات الراي عبر الاضرابات والمظاهرات
السلميه حاولنا عبر النواب ولكن الحكومه
والرئيس يرفضان الاستماع لاي صوت وبالتالي
لم يبقى الا العنف خصوصا ويضربون المثل
بحركه السترات الصفراء التي كانت في
مراحلها الاخيره حركه
واضطرت في ذلك الوقت الحكومه بالفعل
لتقديم مليارات
بدعم المحتاجين ورفع مستوى المعيشه لبعض
الفئات المجتمع الفرنسي فهذا هو الخطير ان
ان الحوار الان يدور حول هل العنف هو
الوسيله الوحيده
بهذا مع التاكيد على ان المظاهرات حتى
الان ما زالت سلميه بنسبه 99% تقريبا ولكن
المواطن الفرنسي العادي لم يعد ينظر الى
هذه الاشتباكات بنفس النظره القديمه بمعنى
كانت هناك ادانه واضحه وصريحه من رجل
الشارع بصوره مستمره وقاطعه لاي اعمال عنف
هذه المره
اختلفت بعض الشيء وان كان رجل الشارع لا
يمارس العنف ولكنه لم يعد يدين ذلك بصوره
واضحه وقاطعه وفوريه اذن هذا الامر خلق
شخص كبير داخل المجتمع الفرنسي شرخ حتى في
مفهوم رجل الشارع للديمقراطيه لانه يعتقد
او يرى ان كل الاساليب الديمقراطيه التي
بارثها لم تؤدي الى ايصال صوته او حتى الى
طرح ما يريد طرحه على طاوله النقاش
بالتالي هو يضع الشارع يضع المتظاهرين يضع
النقابات يضعهم في طريق مسدود عمليا
ويضع نفسه ايضا في تاريخ مسدود لانه وصل
بالخلاف الى درجه حتى لو مر هذا القانون
وتم تطبيقه يبقى السؤال عن كيف سيحكم
مكرون خلال الاربع سنوات القادمه وبينه
وبين الشارع وبين النقابات وبين احزاب
المعارضه هذا الشرخ العميق الذي قد يمنع
او يكون عائق امام اي حوار حقيقي طيب يعني
ستبقى معي سيد وليد لكن قبل ان نعود اليك
والى ايضا ضيوفي الكرام نشاهد هذه الصور
المتداوله ايضا
لمواجهات بين الشرطه الفرنسيه
ومحتجين ايضا
كذلك
اذا هذه صور
ربما لرشقات ايضا من المحتاجين باتجاه
رجال الشرطه الذين يقفون امام بعض المح
ربما التجاريه ومنع تكسير هذه المحاله
التجاريه صدامات اذا بين الشرطه الفرنسيه
ومحتجين في العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس هذا
المشهد كنا قد تابعناه كذلك ايضا في مدينه
نانتال الفرنسيه
وايضا في مدينه كذلك ليون جنوب فرنسا
الصوره
تتكرر المشهد ايضا يتكرر للمواجهات بين
الشرطه الفرنسيه
والمحتجين في باريس المحتجون المؤيدون
ايضا
لاضرابات النقابات العماليه في باريس
وهذه طبعا النقابات التي خرجت الى الشارع
محتجه على رفع سن التقاعد قانون رفع سن
التقاعد من الحكومه الفرنسيه من 62 عاما
الى 64 عاما انتقل الى مرا سل العربيه
فادي الداهوك فادي من باريس
فادي مرحبا بك معي مره اخرى يبدو ان مشهد
المواجهات او الاشتباكات ايضا بين الشرطه
والمحتجين وصل الى باريس الان بعد
ما الذي رصدته
نعم نايف في الموقع الذي انا اتواجد فيه
لا يوجد حولي اشتباكات لكن يمكن ان تكون
هذه الاشتباكات في شارع اخر لان الموكب
طويل وكبير جدا هو ضخم جدا نحن الان في
راس الموكب لكن قد تحدث الان اثناء حديثي
مهاجمه لاحد المصارف كما ترون على الشاشه
هنا مصرف عليه عبارات معاديه او عبارات ضد
وزير الداخليه جيرال درمنا يكتبون ان وزير
الداخليه هو قاتل هذا المصرف لم يحمي
واجهته الزجاجيه لذا من الممكن ان يتم
استهدافه الان خلال لحظات اذا ما كان هناك
عدد من العناصر التي تحدث عنهم وزير
الداخليه لكن ايضا اريد ان اذكر نايف اذا
سمحت لي نقطه مهمه وهو تعليق اضراب عمال
النظافه اعلنوا قبل قليل تعليق اضرابهم
ابتداء من يوم غد تعليق هذا الاضراب الذي
بدا في السادس من مارس وتسبب بتكدس اكثر
من 10000 طن من القمام في شوارع العاصمه
باريس هذا الاضراب اذا هو سيتم تعليقه
ابتداء من الغد لكن ليس لان المطربين
حققوا مطالبهم وانما من اجل البحث عن
طريقه لبدايه الاضراب واعاده اطلاقه بشكل
اقوى لان هناك عدد كبير من العمال
المضربين لا يستطيعون الاستمرار به خصوصا
وانهم لا يتلقون رواتبهم وهم عندما يقومون
او اي عامل عندما يقوم بالاضراب في فرنسا
فانه لا يحصل على
رواتبه لانه يقوم بهذا الاضراب من يومه او
من عمله لذلك هو يعتبر بحكم من اخذ اجازه
من العمل وايضا هذه النقطه مهمه وهي ان
النقابات اعلنت عن جمع حتى الان اكثر من
مليونين و300 الف يورو فرنسي
لمساعده العمال المطربين هذه الاموال تم
جمعها من خلال تبرعات كثيره يتلقاها صندوق
النقابات هذا الاعلان كان قبل يومين وهو
السبب في ان يمكن او في ان يساعد العمال
المضربين على الاستمرار في هذا الاضراب
نايف
ممتاز طيب بالنسبه للحكومه الفرنسيه هل
يعني من جديد في تصريحاتها وتعليقاتها على
هذه الاحتجاجات فادي
ليس هناك حتى الان تعليقات من الحكومه هي
تقول فقط ان هذه الاحتجاجات مشروعه لكن ما
هو ليس مقبولا ان تتحول هذه الاحتجاجات
الى اعمال عنف وشغب وخصوصا الى اشتباكات
مع الشرطه طبعا هناك انقسام حاد جدا بين
الطبقه السياسيه في فرنسا هناك من يدعم
بشكل كبير قوات الشرطه مثل الحزب الجمهوري
او يمين الوسط في فرنسا كذلك وزير
الداخليه لا يعلن عن ادانا لقوات الشرطه
بالرغم من ان هناك تحقيقات فتحت بحق عدد
كبير من عناصرها الذين قاموا بتجاوزاتها
بعمليات اعتقال واعتداء على متظاهرين
وكذلك على صحفيين كان هناك يوم او في
التظاهره السابقه كان هناك اعتداء على عدد
من الصحفيين كل ذلك كان يحدث في اجواء من
الفوضى العارمه والتوتر بين كل الاطراف
بين الشرطه وبين المتظاهرين ايضا هناك
اصابات تقع في صفوف قوات الشرطه هناك
عناصر الشرطه يسقطون ارضا من دون ان يمسه
احدهم فقط من من شده التعب لانهم مستنفرين
منذ اسابيع لمواكبه هذه التظاهرات نراهم
يتساقطون ارضا ويتم نقلهم الى المستشفيات
لتلقي العلاج كذلك هناك المتظاهرين الذين
يقومون بقذف هؤلاء العناصر
بالحجاره بالزجاجات وايضا بالزجاجات
الحارقه لذلك هناك حاله من التوتر الشديد
تعم هذه التظاهرات منذ اسابيع حتى الان
الموكب الباريسي كما ذكرت هو هادئ نسبيا
لا يوجد اشتباكات لكن من المتوقع بشكل
كبير ان تبدا هذه الاشتباكات في الساعات
المقبله اشكرك جزيل الشكر على كل هذه
المعلومات ابقى معي فادي الدهوكم راسل
العربيه من باريس واتوجه ايضا الى ضيفي من
باريس المحلل السياسي
اندريه يعني هل هناك رابط او تشابه او
يعني حاله مرتبطه ببعضها البعض يعني ما
حدث في وقت السترات الصفر وما يحدث اليوم
من الشارع المحتج على رفع قانون سن
التقاعد
لا يعني الرابط هو واحد هو هذه النقمه على
طريقه اداره شؤون الدوله في ولايتي الاولى
والثانيه هذه الطريقه التي يريد من خلالها
ان يتفرد نوعا ما بالحكم نذكر جميع بانه
خلاله ولاياته الاولى
عمليا
بتحجيم كل الاحزاب السياسيه وحتى النقابات
العماليه لم يعد لها دور او اي حضور خلال
ولايته الاولى وبهذه الطريقه يعني يعتقد
بانه سيكون السيد الوحيد المط
لق ثلاث شؤون الدوله اي اي قوه موازيه او
شريك اليوم هذه القوه كما قال الضيف الاخر
وليد عباس يعني بدات تستعيد موقعها بالاخص
النقابات وبدات اليوم كلها مجمعه على انه
طريقه المعالجه هذه لم تعد ناجحه بالنسبه
بالنسبه للمجتمع الفرنسي النكمه واحده
ايضا على الاوضاع المعيشيه
السترات السفر كان موضوع انطلق بدايه من
سبب الغلاء في في المحروقات
وتوسع وانضم اليه القطاعات اخرى اليوم هذا
الامر هو يطاول ليس فقط قطاع واحد من
العمال او من الموظفين او المواطنين
الفرنسيين
اي عامل كان مهما كانت نوع عمله او الطبقه
الاجتماعيه لانه يتعلق بسن التقاعد ولكن
هناك دائما اصوات تحاول ان تجد سبيلا
للتهدئه يعني مكروه عليه ان يعل بان ما
كان متاحا له متيسنا في الولايه الاولى
بالاخص في سنتين الاولتين من ولايته لم
يعد موجودا الان هناك داخل صفوف الحزب
الحاكم او الغالبيه الحاكمه نوع من
التململ
من الضبع في هذه الصفوف
الاحزاب لا تستعيد موقعها نحن اليوم كما
يقول
رئيس العامه
حاجه الى مرحله استراحه الى وقفه لمده شهر
او شهر ونصف من اجل تهدئه الامور
والانطلاق بفكر يعني
دكتور محمد كلشي اختم معك واريد السؤال
هنا عن التوقع لمستقبل ايمانويل ماكرون
كيف سيحكم فيما تبقى له من سنوات
اربع بالنظر الى يعني هذه الاحتجاجات الى
عدم الرضا وعدم الثقه ربما التي تولدت
والتي ذكرها بعطي ضيوفنا قبل قليل من هذا
القرار الذي لم يصوت عليه طبعا في
البرلمان الفرنسي
المؤكد انه سيكون على رئيس ماكرون
ان يواجه صعوبه كبيره في تمرير مشاريع
قوانين لاحقه داخل المجلس النيابي هذا
مشروع قانون اصلاح التقاعد هذا كان عائقا
كبيرا امام المشاريع اللاحقه هناك مشاريع
مقرر ان تطرح على المجلس النيابي لكن
طريقه التعامل مع المجلس النيابي في
بالنسبه لهذه المشاريع لن تعود
كذابها كما حصل مع مشروع قانون اصلاح
التقاعد المهام مهام الحكومه بالنسبه اي
حكومه كانت
لاحقا في تعاطيها مع مشاريع القانون
القوانين اللاحقه ستكون في مواجهه صعبه
جدا مع المجلس النيابي وستاخذ الحكومات
اللاحقه هذه المساله بعد الاعتبار طبعا
اشكرك الشكر من باريس المحله الاساسي
دكتور محمد كلش وايضا كذلك اشكر ضيفي
الاخر من باريس المحلل السياسي اندريه
مهاود وكذلك اشكر مراسل العربيه
الزميل فادي الداهوك والذي سيبقى معنا
ايضا لمتابعه هذه التطورات في فرنسا هذه
الاحتجاجات التي كنا قد تابعنا واياكم منذ
ظهور اليوم بدايه هذه الاحتجاجات التي
انطلقت مساحه الجمهوريه باتجاه ساحه
البسيل وفي عدد ايضا الباستيل عفوا في عدد
ايضا كذلك من المدن الفرنسيه شكرا لكم
الكلمه الان للزميل طالب كنعان في
استديوهات العربيه من دبي